i'm gonna tell you one of the worst
things that happened to me okay uh
i'm having like a phenomenal shoe for
those people that play blackjack a shoe
is uh you know a deck of cards and
you're going through it
and you know it's just going great i'm
hot and
there's a hand where i get like two
eights
and i bet you know i bet a uh ridiculous
amount of money
on the hand and i'm like all right well
i gotta split that you know i'm i'm
talking too much what does the dealer
have when you uh the dealer had a six
showing oh
six shots i never forget this uh and i
got two eights and i'm like oh i gotta
split that
so i split em and i get another eight
and i was like oh hey scared money don't
make no money
uh all right all right let's go
i'm so excited i split them i give me no
no
split that one too another eight four
eights out there i just split them all
at this point little piece of poop came
out my butt at this point
at this point i'm extremely i'm
extremely nervous because i've never
seen anything like this
but it's people around so i'm trying to
play it cool i'm like hey hey all right
okay all right all right what now what
we gotta do now
hit that hit the first one a three come
out
the dealer looks at me she's like you
got to double down i was like
yeah yeah i know i know
i got to do that i got to double down on
that let's go ahead and double down
she said you want to see it face up or
down said i don't want to see it
she put it down the next one comes out
it's a two
so now i got a 10 she goes oh my god got
a double tail again
at this point my palms are sweating at
this point
i said i don't want to see it face down
okay the next car comes out
i get a 10 so i got 18 on the last one i
had another 10.
the dealer had a six showing okay all
right
here we go it's go time the dealer
turns over the card underneath it
in slow motion it was i saw it it was a
five i said
i said you you got to be
not like this not like this
i'm like go slow go slow go slow
dealers you know dealers are fast to the
point where you can't count like you
haven't you ever tried to add it up but
you don't know where you're at
so so i know it's a five out there right
she had the five
boop real fast it was a three i was like
oh oh oh what's that what's that
she's like are you ready i said no no
count that what is that what is that
okay all right all right you got 14. all
right go slow
go slow real fast ace
eight oh my god what's going on what you
got
15. like slow motion i've never seen
anything like it in my life
real fast what 6 21 she took the money
look she she didn't even look me in the
eye she said
i just sat there i kept counting it i
was like hold on wait wait hold on
eleven plus three that's the 14. you got
an ace
ace that puts you all right right there
i think you got to
hold on wait a minute wait a second all
right what i have what are these
what do i have lift all that up that's
nothing or this ain't nothing
none of this is nothing huh here's what
pissed me off there's a guy behind me
he goes man that's crazy ain't it
it's very serious people i suffered a
very serious injury this weekend yeah
in disney world i was with my kids jay
and i uh i took my kids tubing and i
know it doesn't sound like it's that
that's serious at first but i was on the
tube with my kids and
the guy goes hey man for adults you know
we can speed this thing up right i'm a
daredevil you know that
okay i'm a thug jay uh my background
speaks for itself i've been to jail
listen what i'm saying so we get off of
the tube
i'm like yeah i want to do it so he's
got me and my brother we're both getting
set for twos
speed boat starts pulling at 70 miles
per hour i'm not lying
okay we hit a wave right now because i'm
so small
because of my height i'm aerodynamic not
on purpose
not on purpose but we hit the wave bow i
shoot up in the air
now i was scared at first but then in my
mind i started thinking like oh i'ma
stick it like i'm gonna come down
and people are watching they're going
like oh this is probably what kevin hart
does on the side
so i was like okay so i came down right
but i'm staring the tube as i'm coming
down
i land now you know water is water's
hard like you know
if you hit it hard it's like concrete so
i smacked the water with the tube
right i don't know i'm hurt at the time
i hear everybody on the boat
they're like oh my god kevin it sounded
just like that they're like
it was like oh my god kevin okay
yeah these are all white people on the
boat no no no
[Applause]
it was it was like the instructor and my
kids they were like oh my god kevin
so i came down now when i came down i
hit the
i hit the tube and i bounced off into
the water i'm thinking i'm still
fine i go to swim like literally with
this stroke i go to take a swat a stroke
but this shoulder had popped out of
socket i just thought that something i
thought i was like
like you know i don't know who's had a
dislocated shoulder not but if it's this
okay you literally
had you don't have much feeling at the
bottom so i was like oh my arm must be
caught on the tube
so that's the only reason it's not
coming back up
so so once i saw i couldn't get it up
this is when i started to panic a little
bit
i didn't cry but you probably would have
thought that that's what it was
because
so like at this point in time i'm
flagging a guy because i want help i'm
like
this this idiot this jackass is giving
me a thumbs up you did it i'm like
no no i can't move it
they come they get me out the water and
uh my brother was like oh man he said
dude
i could see your shoulder and like you
know you're fine until you see it
like once i saw it like it's just how
remember when you had your jammed toe
at that time you remember right remember
you were fine someone was like shaq you
jammed your toe
[Applause]
that's not shaq cries
it was the same thing it was the same
thing so i saw it i panicked i lied to
you not i passed out like
because i saw my shoulder out the socket
he was like you're going to be all right
and i was like too late i'm going
it was over i woke up in the hospital it
was popped back in yeah i tell you
i tell you a funny [ __ ] on yourself
story not this isn't going to be the guy
with the [ __ ] jokes
uh steven seagal right steve is a goal
uh i'm doing a that's another movie
what are you teaching how to do no this
is this is going to kill you
he's going to kill you so we're doing uh
we're doing round along two
cube accidentally punched one of the
stunt guys right in the nose
who's cube ice cube another i gotta
introduce you he'll love it
he punches the stunt guy in the nose
stunt guy's nose starts bleeding q is
apologetic yo man i'm so sorry
god i'm i'm sorry i think no no man it's
okay like at least you're nice
you know like i noticed it wasn't
intentional we've worked with people in
the past that have been
just dicks right so he's like who i'm
like who else he's like with steven's
goal you know he used to really get
shots in you know
in these scenes so got to a point we had
to come
to our boss you know the stunt
coordinator we were like hey man
steven's really hitting us
like can you kind of tell him to sound
like he's locked down his wife said the
same thing
can you tell steve to relax a little bit
so stephen found out that one of the
guys
was like a black belt in judo like a a
serious black belt so stephen comes up
to the guy he's like hey
put me in your best hold i bet you i can
get out of it and he's like i can't do
that you know you
you're my boss i can't do that to you
he's like put me in your best hole
he looks at his balls because stephen
was being a dick the guy said go ahead
do it
choke stephen put him in a chokehold
right
stephen's struggling his feet his feet
squaming
searching for balance he can't it's like
he's losing air a little bit but you
know the you got to tap out when you
don't want anymore
so while you're here
all you hear is
he taps out he taps out
it goes good good old and he just he
belongs
to the bathroom he he comes out
smells like [ __ ] everywhere the guy
choked the [ __ ] out of the car
but literally
we're at probably one of the funniest
things i've ever seen
okay and people that know let's i want
to ask you everybody take a look at this
video and we're going to
ask you to kind of narrate what was
happening take a look at this video
[Applause]
first of all first of all i know it
looks bad with me running into the
camera
okay uh let me explain y'all what's
going on all right it was a um
it was puffy's party all right puff had
a party uh he's called me said kev
can you host a party with me i said yeah
dude that's how i do it i said i'm in
new york so
he said look we create this little sexy
scene in the bathroom
it's gonna be girls in the tub you trey
songs
fabulous like it's nice it's just gonna
look like it's the place to be we're
gonna use streaming that's all that's
gonna be hot
so get up there i'm hosting you know
first of all i'm a sex symbol
okay so
i'm up there i'm up there and i'm
hosting you know i'm
i'm promoting the party i'm like yeah
man this is a nice event you see we up
here in the tub
i hear trey songz behind me first of all
if somebody here is on fire it's a panic
you know it's a yellow yo yo your hair
it should be crazy
you would have thought trey was singing
this is all i heard i heard
yo your hair's on fire
[Applause]
it was like an hour like like it was one
of his tracks like yo your head's on
fire
i turned around i saw it i was like oh
because like literally like the flame
like george
like the flame grew like it was like it
was like somebody threw gasoline on it
like so when i saw i was like ow ow
so my first instinct was to save myself
because
you know at the end of the day
it's the truth at the end of the day i
don't i don't want to die
you know i don't know if you guys know
weaves are the most flammable thank god
a weed if there would have been another
girl next to a weed that thing would
have caught faster than the forest fire
so i said so i just said let me say it
myself
now to camera i run i'm like did you get
that on tape
the only reason why i said that is
because i didn't really get to see the
whole thing
so i wanted to i want to see it over
again for myself as reasons
let's take a look at it one more time
everybody let's see it
what level did you get to uh as far as
basketball goes did you play high school
basketball
uh okay we being honest like because
yeah
cause you can find footage so i don't
know how far i can lie okay
uh all right listen i played i played
high school basketball i played
four years of varsity but it wasn't it
wasn't easy okay
um i wanted to play real bad this is all
i wanted to do
my mom she didn't want me to try out
because my school
was like two hours from my house we had
to catch public transportation
and the tryouts for the basketball team
was at 6am this is a true story
and my mom was like you're not leaving
our house at 4am
to go try out for a basketball team
there's all types of crazy people out
here
i'm not sending my son on public
transportation at that time i was like
mom but this is the tryouts like i want
to be on the team
that's when i get to be on team she's
like no not going to happen
so because i'm such a genius i decided
to take all the clocks in the house
and set all of the clocks forward so
when it was really 4 a.m i set the
clocks to say 6 a.m
that's what time i was leaving so like i
woke my mom up and everything like it
was time for work
i got to get up she was like it's still
dark out what's going on today
i don't know but we gotta get up out of
here time to go
vcrs clocks her watches everything i set
every clock in the house and i made it
to tryouts i tried out
and i was happy my plan worked and
midway through the day i remember being
in class you know
classrooms got those skinny windows
right and i'm like doing my work and i
remember a head
popping in the window
and it was my mind and my mom
and i remember the teachers like mr hart
your mother wants to see you and i was
like
don't don't let me go out there for
myself he's like
go ahead mrs hart you excuse nothing no
no please you gotta come out there
and i remember walking out in that hall
and all i heard us say was
you had me get to work two hours early
but nobody else in the office but me she
beat me
all the way home every bus we got on she
hit me
had me on the bus with nobody else on
the bus
the train i never i think i got whoop i
may have gotten whooped for three and a
half hours straight
and there was nothing i could say and i
was happy because i made the team
and she was like oh you made the team i
made the team